je serais bref je viens juste de
recueillir la réaction de la famille de
la route de ses parents de ses deux
jeunes soeurs également qui ont suivi
pas à pas cette longue audience ils ont
le sens reste éveillé toute la nuit
siens pour savoir ce qui s'était passé
aujourd'hui
il tenait un chien par mon intermédiaire
aujourd'hui a rappelé que hier jeudi 23
juillet 2020 le jour de l'extradition de
nicolas zepeda nord me kroes là qui
aurait dû fêter son 25ème anniversaire
et il souhaite elle rappelé parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'audience a été centré
sur nikola zepeda sur son placement en
détention qui vient d'être annoncée mais
il souhaitait rappeler le souvenir de
leur fille parce que pour eux cette
journée anniversaire a été une journée
de deuil et qu' ils espèrent toujours de
manière réitérée à obtenir des réponses
je ne vous cache pas que ils sont
effondrés
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'ils
espéraient malgré tout que des
révélations seraient fait est que j'ai
dû leur apprendre que nicolas zepeda
reste sur un positionnement liée à son
innocence par conséquent cela les a
plongés dans une véritable détresse mais
ils entretiennent cet espoir il voudrait
supplié ses sont les thèmes qu'ils
utilisent suppliait nicolas zepeda de
leur révéler un chien le lieu où se
trouve narumi parce que la place d'une
armée est près de ses parents et qu' ils
ne peuvent plus rester dans cet état de
détresse
cette torture qui perdure depuis depuis
bientôt quatre ans et enfin
j'en terminerai par là il souhaitait
également remercier monsieur le
procureur de la république etienne
manteaux pour sa pugnacité et grâce à
qui aujourd'hui cette extradition je
pense a pu être mené à bien et ils s'en
tiennent à des observations que vous les
formules et parce qu'il s'agit de
personnes très très digne et très
d'istres qui ne souhaite pas s'étendre
davantage